hey race fans it's time to start those
engines with forza horizon 5 out in the
wild reaching 10 million gamers and
becoming xbox's biggest launch to date
we figured it was the perfect time to
look back at all of the games in the
series motorsport and horizon to see
just how far it's come so buckle up as
we take a ride down memory lane and rank
all 14 games for more on forza make sure
you're subscribed to gamespot
forza street is a free-to-play spin-off
specifically developed for mobile yes
forza has a mobile game and if you
didn't know now you know it features a
very distinct and unique setup from the
main series with players being
responsible for breaking and
accelerating only the game takes control
of the steering forza street is also
available on pc but it doesn't exactly
compare to the rest of the series when
it comes to presentation gameplay
features and support
this standalone racing game features
about a dozen cars from the fast and
furious franchise including some that
debuted in furious 7 which was the
latest entry at the time the game also
featured familiar characters like ted
parker with ludicrous joining and
voicing the expert mechanic as for the
gameplay it involved taking part in
over-the-top racing challenges set in
france just like the movie i'd even
argue that this is better than the full
fast and furious games
i was addicted to motorsport 2. it was
the first sim racer to grab my attention
and keep it for hours and hours on end
if i wasn't playing halo 3 or modern
warfare you best believe i was most
likely playing this featuring more than
300 cars from 50 manufacturers and a
dozen tracks forza motorsport 2 offers
many different ways to play to suit your
style and its assists were a welcome
addition for players just learning the
ropes like me the game was praised for
its innovations at the time like menus
that told you where your car was damaged
and the temperature of your tires to
simulate the real driving experience
released back in 2009 forza motorsport 3
was celebrated for being a step up from
his predecessor in almost every way
among its many different features was a
rewind button that allowed players to
skip back in time after they crash or
make a wrong move the racing game was
also praised for its online modes which
delivered new ways to play both with
friends in a private match and against
the community at large there were new
drag and drift events along with
team-based cat and mouse tournaments
that afforded new ways to play
2011's forza motorsport 4 is perhaps
best remembered for releasing around the
time that microsoft was pushing its
camera base connect technology the
camera would track player's head so that
they can look around or it could just
control the car microsoft would go on to
discontinue connect but forza motorsport
4 showcased how such a setup could have
worked outside of the connect
integration forza motorsport 4 chains
things up with its world tour mode and
made changes to how players unlock cars
and once again the game was praised for
its ability to cater to new players of
all types of skill
levels the very first forza motorsport
game was released in 2005 the game
introduced xbox fans to the simulation
style racing series that would go on to
spawn numerous sequels and spin-offs the
original game was generally praised by
critics and here at gamespot we scored
it a 9.2 with praise directed towards
the game's ability to mesh advanced sim
elements into a package that was
generally acceptable to newcomers it's a
design philosophy that has carried
forward throughout the years across its
numerous installments the game certainly
looks dated by today's standards but it
proved to be a big success that became
one of microsoft's most celebrated
franchises overall
and just when i was getting sick of need
for speed games the first forza horizon
was released for xbox 360. microsoft
tapped playground games to develop the
game and the big change from the main
forza motorsport series is that horizon
is focused on non-track races and
off-road competition in a big open world
the first horizon is set in colorado and
sees players taking part in various
races and competitions to make their way
through the horizon festival where the
game gets its name it will go on to
spawn multiple sequels and help elevate
and differentiate the forza series
overall
2013's forza motorsport 5 was the first
entry released on the new at the time
xbox one console it was actually a
launch title for the xbox one and
microsoft went all out recruiting top
gear hosts jeremy clarkson james may and
richard heyman for voice roles in the
game's campaign
the game boasted gorgeous graphics for
the time showing off what the xbox one
was capable of the racing game also
pushed the franchise forward with clever
use of the xbox one triggers to provide
haptic feedback about traction and
stability
[Music]
2014's forza horizon 2 was the second
entry in the spin-off series and the
first on xbox one set in picturesque
locations across france and italy forza
horizon 2 took some of the action
off-road with races across fields and
dirt giving players a new type of
driving experience similar in structure
to the first game forza horizon 2 has
players taking part in various events
across the campaign that unlocks more
and more cars and settings as the game
progresses
2015's forza motorsport 6 introduced a
seemingly small but important element to
the series
wet weather not only did the rain make
for some unique artistic flair in the
overall look of the game but wet weather
changed driving conditions and this made
an impact on how the game was played and
what you needed to do in order to
succeed on a track during a downpour
knight races were added to motorsport 6
as well adding another layer to mix
things up
the forza motorsport series continued in
2017 with forza motorsport 7 on xbox one
at the time boasting to be the quote
most comprehensive beautiful and
authentic racing game ever made the game
was indeed a nice visual step up
boasting a 4k 60fps experience the game
added new environmental and weather
effects and the rain in particular
glistened in stunning detail there were
an overwhelming 700 plus cars in the
game and 30 famous real world tracks to
race on similar to past games in the
series forza motorsport 7 was also
praised for its feature set that offered
enough for season fans to enjoy and was
also approachable enough for newcomers
forza horizon 3 iterated and improved
upon the first two releases in a number
of ways released in 2016 and set in the
sprawling and gorgeous environments of
australia forza horizon 3 introduced
stunning sky boxes that were based on
real photographs and video has more than
350 cars and is set on what was the
biggest forza horizon map at the time
the game featured new ways to race and
drive and in traditional forza fashion
there were special showcase events
featuring races against speed boats and
airships
released in 2018 forza horizon 4 was
seemingly a special one for developer
playground games being a home game of
sorts with its setting in great britain
in addition to its stunning environments
and sweeping landscapes forza horizon 4
is known for introducing changing
seasons to the franchise letting fans
experience winter spring summer and fall
complete with gameplay relevant changes
to the environment the game also
featured more of an online focus with
dozens of players on a single server
together after launch the game welcomed
numerous expansion packs including those
themed around hot wheels and james bond
the game also leaned into the battle
royale trend with its eliminator mode
horizon 5 the latest in the series takes
place across a vast mexican landscape
roughly 50 percent larger than the map
of horizon 4. there's jungle desert dirt
asphalt and even a volcano and location
aside the game includes new features
like horizon arcade and event lap adding
a whole new layer of replayability while
still keeping hits like the eliminator
there are even character driven story
beats where for the first time in the
series your character talks back to npcs
these moments shake up the established
horizon formula and help the title stand
out amongst its family of other forza
games and whether you're playing on xbox
one xbox series x or a pc horizon 5 is
still a technical and visual treat
hit the comment section and let us know
which of the forza games is your
favorite like this video if you enjoyed
it and make sure you subscribe to
gamespot for more on forza and
everything else under the video game sun
[Music]
you